[Musica]
voglio raccontarvi una storia la storia
di un bambino un bambino che è circa
vent'anni fa si collega a internet per
la prima volta quelli sono gli anni in
cui nelson mandela è da poco presidente
del sudafrica sta per uscire il primo
toy story e i modem fanno ancora quel
rumore un po fastidioso tipo ping ping
ping ping pubblico compton su internet
questo bambino scopre un mondo
straordinario un mondo dove finalmente
può trovare i trucchi per il suo
videogioco preferito un mondo dove può
ammettersi a pubblicare piccole poesie
racconti su forum sperduti un mondo
grazie al quale comincia anche a
chattare con una ragazzina del
connecticut
anche se il suo inglese diciamo che
ancora abbastanza incerto per usare un
eufemismo quel bambino di venti anni fa
sono io
e oggi che sul web ci scrivo e ci lavoro
voglio parlarvi di qualcosa che mi sta
molto a cuore qualcosa che stavolta non
mi vede entusiasta ma al contrario un po
un po preoccupato
infatti qualche giorno fa ero sul sito
della cnn e vedo una notizia che che mi
sconvolge mi sconvolge abbastanza qual
cosa successa a washington negli stati
uniti
immaginate la scena un uomo entra in una
pizzeria una pizzeria normalissima cioè
il via vai dei camerieri
sono i clienti che chiacchierano
nell'aria si sente l'odore del le salse
dei formaggi il problema è che
quest'uomo ha un fucile in mano e appena
entra lo punta dritto dritto al primo
cameriere che incontra il cameriere
rimane impietrito si scatena il panico
la gente inizia a urlare a scappare per
fortuna dopo pochi minuti arrivano le
sirene della polizia
nessuno si fa male l'uomo viene
arrestato ma perché era lì era lì dirà
la polizia perché era andato a indagare
sul cosiddetto pizza gate un presunto
scandalo
una notizia in realtà completamente
inventata secondo cui hillary clinton e
alcuni membri del suo partito sarebbero
stati coinvolti in una rete di pedofilia
internazionale
una notizia completamente falsa punto
qualcosa è nata sul web diffusa nel web
che non aveva nessun fondamento ecco è
in momenti come questo che quel bambino
innamorato di internet si chiede io mi
chiedo cosa è andato storto cosa cosa è
successo e cosa porta
oggi internet a essere anche questo come
è possibile che uno strumento di
creazione di condivisione di scoperta
sia anche possibile causa di morti e di
feriti e sicuramente causa di di molto
di grande panico
non so darmi una risposta certa quello
che pensa che internet ha messo nelle
mani di tutti noi una uno strumento
potentissimo che ancora forse non
abbiamo ancora imparato a utilizzare
appieno ea comprendere appieno uno
strumento nei confronti del quale molte
persone nutrono una fiducia
incondizionata una fiducia esagerata
una fiducia che purtroppo non riguarda
solamente gli utenti comuni le persone
forse non
avvezzi alla tecnologia ma riguarda
spesso proprio coloro i quali dovrebbero
essere i garanti della nostra
informazione i giornalisti a tal
proposito qualche tempo fa ho fatto un
piccolo esperimento ho inserito in
alcune voci di wikipedia delle citazioni
inventate associandole a dei personaggi
molto noti
niente di offensivo pericoloso
semplicemente delle frasi che queste
persone avrebbero potuto realmente dire
come nel caso di un noto politico il
leader spirituale della del suo partito
all'interno della cui voce scrissi a b
scrissi a un giovane direi ab valori
come bussola della tua nave e non aver
paura di navigare il mondo bene con mia
grande sorpresa questa frase che è
appunto questo ma non sa non ha in
realtà mai pronunciato fini non solo su
piccoli siti e piccoli magazine
ma su grosse testate giornalistiche
canali televisivi nazionali
finì addirittura nel discorso ufficiale
della loro a sindaco di milano
beh allora viene da chiedersi se se
anche i giornalisti alcuni giornalisti
non non riescono a comprendere questi
meccanismi non riescono a bagnare le
fonti non riescono a discernere il vero
dal falso che speranze abbiamo noi
comuni mortali di fronte di fronte a
tutto questo il risultato è abbastanza
chiaro ed evidente lo vediamo ogni
giorno nelle bacheche nei feed
su tutti i canali internet dove vediamo
ogni giorno decine e decine di bufale
diffondersi per il web bufale che
riguardano la politica l'economia la
scienza a volte al limite del ridicolo
altre volte quasi diciamo credibili ma
comunque notizie al cento per cento
false notizie
e diffondono spesso disinformazione che
fomentano odio che che ci danneggiano su
tutti i livelli
bufale che sono costruite con un unico
intento quello di raccogliere click
ricevere click
quanti più click possibile click che
nell'economia di internet vogliono dire
semplicemente guadagni infatti è per
questo che la maggior parte dei
fabbricanti di bufale appunto fa fa
queste operazioni per una questione di
guadagno
l'economia del clic della
visualizzazione è però non riguarda
solamente loro riguarda anche i
giornalisti i giorni il i giornalisti
serino non i creatori di finte notizie
infatti questo impatta su vari livelli
il giornalismo oggi sta subendo una fase
di transizione di trasformazione alcuni
giornalisti autorevoli dicono che il
modello tradizionale quello basato sulla
credibilità del giornalista non funziona
più e questo porta a due cose da una
parte alcuni giornali e giornalisti
reagiscono appiattendosi su queste
stesse tattiche di acchiappa click
dall'altra parte altri invece cercano di
innovare di sperimentare di trovare
nuovi modelli
possiamo sicuramente trovare tanti
attori in questo scenario possiamo
cercare di capire queste dinamiche in
tanti modi ma al centro di tutto c'è
sempre lui c'è sempre il clik clik che
nel corso della rivoluzione nel corso
delle varie rivoluzioni ha avuto un
ruolo molto molto importante
clicc primavera araba click
il video di un artista diventa virale
click
posso fare arrivare la la mia pubblicità
online solamente gli abitanti di napoli
fra i 25 ei 30 anni appassionati di
serie tv e anche vegetariani poi magari
si scopre che ce ne solamente uno ma al
di là di questo il discorso è che oggi
voglio parlarvi di un'altra rivoluzione
una rivoluzione è un po diversa
la rivoluzione del non fare clic col
mouse del non fare tap col pollice del
non cliccare su pubblica con dvd like o
perlomeno del farlo con più
consapevolezza
ecco perché secondo me c'è qualcosa che
dovremmo iniziare a fare qualcosa di
semplice che dovremmo iniziare a fare e
soprattutto incoraggiare altri a fare ed
è una città molto molto semplice prima
di fare clic
contiamo fino a 10 perché nelle nostre
mani nei nostri smartphone nei nostri
mouse c'è un potere più grande è molto
più grande di quello che che noi
immaginiamo si è molto parlato delle
elezioni presidenziali negli stati uniti
di quanto per la prima volta nella
storia una enorme massa di bufale abbia
caratterizzato questo questo periodo
alcuni hanno detto che addirittura le
bufale hanno impattato molto molto
significativamente sull'esito del voto
ma al di là del giudizio politico della
dell'analisi politica quello che quello
che fa impressione ella la quantità la
quantità di siti e di contenuti
completamente falsi sull'argomento
pensate solamente a velez che è una
cittadina della romania di soia di soli
50 mila abitanti
solamente qui hanno trovato 140 siti
dedicati esclusivamente
questo scopo avevano dei finti nomi di
magazine tipo i 26 conserve dei giudei o
cose del genere
sembravano giornali ma non lo erano
appunto 140 siti gestiti soprattutto da
teenager bene vedete è stato preso e
stato chiamato in causa il re dei social
network facebook in quanto il suo ruolo
e la sua presenza vengono discussi come
elementi che hanno favorito la
diffusione di queste bufale vengono
chiamati in causa i grossi plate con
tecnologici
facebook ha in un primo momento si è si
è difeso da queste accuse in un secondo
momento proprio pochi giorni fa ha
annunciato delle vere e proprie
contromisure concrete per combattere la
diffusione di queste bufale il dibattito
fra fra pro o contro è e antico riguardo
la tecnologia da una parte chi dice che
la tecnologia è la panacea di tutti i
mali dall'altra chi dice che è invece il
male assoluto
io penso che possiamo riconoscere
semplicemente che la tecnologia ha sì le
sue responsabilità deve evolversi in
qualche modo ma allo stesso tempo
dobbiamo dobbiamo evolverci noi il
censis ci dice che il 35 per cento degli
italiani si informa soprattutto su
facebook infatti è vero che queste
grosse piattaforme hanno un'anima sempre
meno tech è sempre più media ci hanno un
impatto sempre più forte su come le
informazioni vengono condivise diffuse
in rete
dall'altra parte però ci sono dei dati
che fanno molto molto riflettere una
ricerca della columbia dice che
addirittura il 59 per cento di tutti gli
articoli condivisi in rete non è mai
stato eletto questo vuol dire che
milioni e milioni di utenti si passano
di loro dei contenuti che non hanno
nemmeno letto contenuti magari
caratterizzati da un titolo accattivante
acchiappa click
proprio questi titoli a volte sembrano
costruiti in maniera ingenua sembrano
quasi ridicoli ma realtà i nostri
avversari in questa battaglia contro
contro le bufale sono molto meno ingenui
di quanto pensavo conoscono la mente
umana molto meglio di quanto di quanto
noi pensiamo e daniel cane ma in uno
psicologo e premio nobel ha spiegato la
differenza fra i due principali sistemi
di pensiero che portano all'azione umana
da una parte il pensiero veloce quello
immediato istintivo emotivo quello che
si basa su pochi input solamente un
input molto spesso il sistema di
pensiero che ha permesso all uomo
primitivo di sopravvivere di combattere
le minacce esterne
dall'altra parte il pensiero lento
razionale che ha bisogno di tanti
stimoli che ha bisogno di più tempo e
più risorse cognitive
è vero sì che ci siamo evoluti
ci siamo evoluti sì ma fino a un certo
punto forte di quel software mentale se
così lo possiamo chiamare è sempre lo
stesso e questo lo sanno bene i nostri
avversari i fabbricanti di bufale per
che costruiscono la loro comunicazione
basandosi sempre sull'idea di questo
nemico un nemico sempre cattivo
non importa che il nemico siano i
migranti sia il politico di turno sia
una scoperta scientifica importante che
questo nemico sia sempre caratterizzato
come cattivo bugiardo dannoso e e non
basta non si ferma qui perché queste
persone non queste persone accompagnano
queste finte notizie da un linguaggio
molto preciso un linguaggio
molto violento un linguaggio che
pretende di svelare la verità
e poi chiede anche che questa venga
condivisa in maniera immediata
condividi adesso retweet a questa è la
verità ci stanno imbrogliando adesso
loro vogliono che che noi non perdiamo
nemmeno un secondo a ad agire a
condividere a fare quello che sa fare
quello che dicono
figuriamoci contare fino a dieci e
diciamo che vorrei farvi una domanda
sapete qual è l'emozione che genera il
più alto tasso di click
questa emozione è la rabbia la rabbia e
la pancia sulla base della quale molti
vorrebbero che noi prendessimo le nostre
decisioni e che vi dico non clicchiamo
con la pancia anche perché sarebbe un po
scomodo ma il fatto è che non voglio
rassegnarmi alla parola dell'anno post
verità che equivale a dire che i fatti e
le finzioni stanno sullo stesso piano
abbiamo secondo me è una grossa
responsabilità e allora diciamolo a
tutti diciamo ai nostri amici ai nostri
conoscenti nostri parenti prima di fare
clic
contiamo fino a 10 perché internet non
sta sulle spalle di una persona sola
come la leggenda di atlante che regge
una volta celeste interessava sulle
spalle di tutti noi e se tutti noi ci
prendiamo un pezzetto forse il carico
sarà più leggero
abbiamo una forte un forte ruolo la
nostra libertà come ci ricorda bob dylan
ci porta un alto grado di di
responsabilità
questa situazione vi giuro non l'ho
inventata io
abbiamo una responsabilità verso persone
stessi verso il presente verso chi ci
sta attorno
ma anche e soprattutto una
responsabilità verso il futuro
[Applauso]